i suspect that to
many of you viewers it's not news that i
got covid in late april if you've been
following me in social media or you read
my recent medium piece what kovid has
been teaching me that i'll link to below
it's not a surprise but you might find
interesting sort of the reflections and
experiences that i've been having
as
one symptom in particular
has not
eased up and as i've moved into what
nowadays they're calling by a variety of
names the most prevalent of which is
long coveted so i'm going to talk about
quite a few things in this video i don't
want to hear in comments any conspiracy
theory nonsense or you know stuff like
that or advice i'm not looking for that
sort of thing this is not like an open
forum discussion on it i'm just sharing
my
experiences and my own reflections about
it with people who are interested so if
you're not interested in that you want
to
move away to some other video if you are
interested in it here it is so
like i said um late april you know sort
of the end point of the semester at
milwaukee institute of art and design
where i was teaching three classes
and
not a little past the midpoint for
carthage college where i was also
teaching an online class
and i'm pretty sure where i picked it up
from i you know we've been very careful
my wife and i because
now that i think about i'm actually
immune compromised and so is she so from
the very beginning of the pandemic we've
been careful about you know social
distancing and masking and that sort of
thing we got our vaccinations but you
know lots and lots and lots of people
especially in the the time that i was
getting it wound up getting coveted even
with that
and you know fortunately um the if
you're vaccinated it helps you out quite
a bit
um so i'm pretty sure i got it at
milwaukee institute of art and design
specifically at gallery night you know
at milwaukee institute of art design the
seniors all do senior theses which are
really important projects where you know
it's like a capstone they're bringing
all this and each of them has like their
own little booth
in the various galleries or other places
where these are set up and the
public and the professors and family
members and all sorts of others are
invited to come in and check it out
so i was there and that's pretty you
know i'm pretty sure that's where i
ended up picking it up because lots and
lots of people packed into fairly closed
spaces
i wasn't wearing a mask although i
probably should have been
at that time you know i was getting a
little bit over confident probably and
very few other people were except you
know fortunately a lot of the students
were
and so that that's when i probably
picked it up and you know then a few
days later
i started having some symptoms and i
thought it was actually like seasonal
allergies because i have you know some
pretty bad ones to various kinds of
pollen specifically oak pollen but other
things as well and you know i started
having like you know some sinus pressure
and a runny nose and sneezing a good bit
and some of the congestion was like
getting down into my
chest and i was starting to get a bit
you know fatigued and and you know some
body aches and some joint aches and
you know i'm a kind of person who's in
pain pretty much every day because of
different issues so i i just kind of
wrote that stuff off and i was like ah
you know this this isn't great maybe
i'll take
some painkillers
um you know start getting sinus
headaches and stuff like that
and it got worse and worse and worse and
eventually it got to the point where my
wife looked at me and she's like man you
don't look good at all i was like i
don't feel good and so she's like we
need to take your temperature so she did
and then she's like oh 101 point
something that's pretty high my normal
body temperature is 98.0
i'm a little bit on the cold side so
you know we had at home covid test and
she's like
i think you better take a covet test and
i was like oh okay so i we did it you
know you got to do the nasal swab thing
and stir it around and all that sort of
stuff
and
it you know it could take up to 15
minutes it didn't even take five minutes
before you know the bars appeared and
she's like oh man you've got covid and
you've been sitting
you know next to me we gotta isolate now
so i came upstairs she stayed downstairs
and you know what ensued was
a lot of really careful procedures on
our part to try to make sure that she
didn't get it because it's more
dangerous if if she does even though
that she's you know she was triple
vaxxed and all of that
as well so you know i had to isolate and
you know i was laying in bed much of the
time and trying to drink as much water
as possible
blowing my nose what felt like
constantly
and uh go you know alternating between
sleeping and waking and
um you know fortunately i didn't have
any like nausea or anything like that it
was all like
you know sinus respiratory fatigue that
that sort of thing and you know i i
could you know i was teaching mostly
online classes obviously i couldn't go
in for my face-to-face class
and you know we finished out the
semester
i couldn't do some of the things that
i'd planned to do like
create videos for my medieval philosophy
class because i couldn't get in front of
the chalkboard you know i was i was
too
wiped out
you know so
um that went on for a while i started
feeling better you know the first three
four days were pretty rough but i was
never in danger of hospitalization thank
goodness
and then you know i started feeling
better um you know i could at first i
could only like read really uh easy
breezy science fiction books and i
started reading philosophy stuff again
and i watched my way through a lot of uh
shows and you know that that all that
sort of business and then you know i
started feeling better and better and
then i started getting kind of stir
crazy about being stuck up here
and
um you know then came a negative test
you know good ways in i think maybe what
like
10 days or
some some somewhere around there after
the initial test and so that meant i
could move around the cabinet so to
speak right but i was still pretty you
know
tired and weak and and still having you
know some sinus stuff although most of
the other stuff had gone away and then
it got better and better and better and
um you know finished out the semester
got my grades in
started you know taking short walks and
you know going out and doing things
going going getting some coffee and
stuff like that
and something that i had in
you know the covid itself in the period
of you know like serious infection
didn't go away this this fatigue that
i've been having
that is unpredictable in one sense but
predictable in another sense it's sudden
and it's massive it is like a switch
flipping or like a curtain coming down
you know i'm fine and then i'm wiped out
and that's it for the day basically i
mean i could
watch a show or read a book but i'm not
going to like shoot a video i won't have
the energy to do it
or anything that requires you know
serious thought or you know real
engagement or anything like that
so
this has become a
pretty
you know standard feature you could say
in my post covered life
and this is the sort of thing that
people started saying oh you've got long
coved right and i was like i don't know
if i've had this long enough to have
long covid isn't that more for like
people who are
really having debilitating effects for
months and months afterwards and so
today i went and looked it up and so
there's like a lot of names right long
covered long haul covid postcovid
conditions there's a variety of
different names for this and
the cdc uh which i consider to be
reliable
says that if you're still having
symptoms and they list what the symptoms
would be
four weeks after infection then that can
be considered long coveted so
at this point at the end of may
um yeah it's more than four weeks
it doesn't show signs of really changing
that much although maybe maybe it's
getting a bit better in certain respects
and i'll tell you about that in a minute
um and it's it's quite interesting you
know i found out a lot today by going to
the cdc website you know for example
that
long covid can be considered a
disability under the americans with
disability
act i don't think i qualify for that in
in any way but it's good to know that
it's out there
you know it started provoking a lot of
thinking on my part and my wife's part
you know and she pointed out to me
something that i keep on forgetting
about
namely that i got a compromise system
anyway you know
i've um
you know i when i was a kid in in high
school i had mononucleosis
um i've had limes twice you know
so it's not like um you know my system
is a car fresh off the lot or something
you know i've been i've been running
pretty hard for a long time dealing with
a number of different kinds of illness
for for a while and so it's not all that
you know strange that covid effects
could linger and talking with other
people some of them have a similar
effect and you know for some it went
away for some
it didn't and so you know what are the
things that are relevant again from the
cdc website tiredness or fatigue that
interferes with daily life and they give
you all sorts of examples of you know
interfering with daily life and
yeah that's that's that's the case
i mean my first thing is to think about
my work but it also interferes with
exercise it also interferes with
um getting housework done that i want to
do and you know it's it's uh it's a
thing
and then
symptoms that get worse after physical
or mental effort i think that's kind of
connected to it that's the fatigue gets
gets worse because i work you know
and then i run out of energy and
i'm done you know
and what is this fatigue like i
mentioned
earlier that it is
quite sudden when it happens
um you know you know that you're
fatigued uh as soon as you start feeling
it because it's like it's like somebody
turning a dial instead of like going
first to one then to two then to three
or something like that it's like they go
to seven right away
and it doesn't usually go to go to 10
right or the spinal tap 11. but it's
like a you know a six to eight and it's
it's
pretty
rough i mean i i sometimes i'm like i
gotta lay down
i can't keep doing what i'm doing
um
and it can happen like i said it's
unpredictable
so it could be at two in the afternoon
that's becoming less and less
common though it could be at five
o'clock
it could be
seven o'clock it could be
ten o'clock at but when it hits i am
basically done
and you know since i typically work from
about nine to
you know 10 or 11 at night with you know
breaks and stuff like that um it's it's
cutting into my work time significantly
and other things that i want to do
so you know when i first started having
this um after most of the symptoms went
away i posted about it and you know some
people were sympathetic and they're like
you know
take it easy man uh you know you you
work really hard and you do a lot maybe
you need to rest up and you know dial
back a little bit and that was useful
advice and my wife also gave me that
advice and my dad
you know
also they're all like you're you know
you have a tendency to push yourself a
bit too hard this is not the time to to
push it i also had some some people you
know
it's kind of funny people like to give
advice even if they don't know you at
all about what they did and how you
should do it and and some people gave
some really distinctly unhelpful advice
they're like you know you just gotta
like get back to work and that's what i
did and i was fine and you know
in this case that's actually quite
counterproductive from what what people
say and and i didn't do that i've been
kind of taking it easy
in a measured way i'd like push myself a
bit and then
when i'd get tired as a result i'd back
off you know and then see what i could
do the the next day my own previous
tendencies in the past
have been you know if i get sick
um that's fine then i recover then i get
back up and get on the proverbial horse
and start hard driving again
and
that's probably not going to be
a smart a prudent a rational
approach to this so i've been getting
a good bit of rest some of that rest has
included things like
reading
science fiction fantasy works that i
wanted to get to
i'm very well prepped for the worlds of
speculative fiction stuff
some of it is included you know watching
shows i watched my way through blake
seven which i really enjoyed
um
and uh you know trying to like find ways
to
to take it a bit easier these days and
so it's had a massive effect on my work
life which i'm not super
happy about you know the work
dirt while i had coveted obviously i
wasn't getting much work done at all you
know i did get the grading done i i you
know corresponded with students when i
could
um i did do one conference presentation
which left me totally
worn out and then i you know i did some
other online events here and there
but a little bit more
measured
and so the work wasn't getting done you
know i haven't done that much video
production as i used to or or podcast
production or writing
and um you know my book projects are
kind of on hold
correspondence i got quite a bit far
behind
in that as well
and initially i was projecting all right
i'm going to get better and then like
every other time in the past i'm i'm
already projecting i'm going to get this
done and this done and this done
and
that's not happening
and this also applies to
you know
working out
exercising you know nowadays i take
walks i i you know do weight circuits i
do a few other things as well
you know in the past i would try to like
make up for what i had missed that's
that's not going to be an option anymore
and so i found myself getting like
further and further behind both in terms
of the actual work and also in terms of
like my mindset and this is part of what
i want to talk with you about you know
maybe this demands a different kind of
attitude and perspective
you know because i i found myself having
to deal with frustration
and disappointment
and um you know some some concerns
i wouldn't say they rise to the level of
fears yet but you know maybe they should
about what's my what's my body going to
be capable of in my mind capable of
down the line
and you know i'll cop to it i feel kind
of a sense of um
what would you call it it's not
embarrassment as such it's not shame as
such but it is a you know kind of a bad
feeling like i didn't get this this
stuff done i'm you know i've let people
down
i committed to things and i didn't
accomplish them that doesn't feel good
right so there's some emotional things
that go along with this and you know it
applies not just to my
my work which is a significant portion
of my life but also to you know exercise
to
um doing things like like cooking i
enjoy cooking my wife and i are both
great cooks so we do a lot of cooking at
home
housework i'm you know
i grew up in a household where there's
no such thing as women's work it's
everybody works and everybody cleans and
you know i've been kind of lacked
in that and even you know getting out my
my banjo or my base and playing and
singing
i've i've only done that once uh since
uh since i came down with kovid so
you know there's a lot of changes and
it's over the last week or so and this
goes to that article that i wrote in
medium what covid is teaching me
i'm learning this is this is probably a
longer
term thing that i need to think about i
need to rethink i need to reflect
and i probably need to restructure
especially my work life because it's
such a big part of my
life i've had a lifestyle
boy since
since high school really of like always
doing a lot
doing more than most people do
being kind of hard driving
it's allowed me to build up you know a
huge
number of
videos and podcasts and writings and
things that i've accomplished articles
but
i don't know that i'm going to be able
to sustain that
and you know in the past when i wouldn't
get to something i would kind of put it
off like i'd have a to-do list and maybe
i'd erase like half of the to-do list
for the day and then it would go to the
next day
and i would have illnesses and the
illnesses would result in pushing off to
a later date the stuff that i needed to
get done
but
usually i'd still get it done i'd find a
way to catch up i was put in some more
hours right or something like that
and
in the last decade i've had probably a
more healthy
approach and attitude towards that
than in previous decades but it's still
not where it really needs to be this is
a chance for me to like
take stock of
where i currently am and what i need to
do and where i'm where i'm going
so it's time to to really reconsider
um you know i'm 51 years old i'm
moving you know i've moved into my 50s
this is probably you know this is the
second half of my life whether i live to
80 or 100 if you've you know 50 you're
definitely in the second half and i need
to think about
what i want that to look like you know
there i've probably you know not
probably i've definitely built up some
habits and attitudes when it comes to
work that are going to be
harder and harder to sustain as
as time goes on as my body ages as
it seems like there's always more and
more things to to do
i've been very generous in the past with
my time and attention and work sometimes
even one could say kind of thoughtless
or reckless with it saying yes yes yes
to so many
things and and maybe i need to start you
know reconsidering
that and being more selective being more
prudent about what i
what i say yes to you know and in part i
should think about well you know what is
going to
build up the kind of projects that i
want built up what's valuable in that
sense and what what actually gives me uh
joy or excitement what's a drag i should
maybe start cutting out some of the
things that i
find to be just a chore or dull or you
know not really my thing where can i
have some some serious impact for good
or to prevent bad from happening and you
know where do my where my duties and and
commitments and obligations why these
are all the sort of things that i need
to start really thinking more about
rather than just
consuming time as a resource rather than
being thoughtful about that stuff i also
have to take into account i don't know
how long this fatigue is going to go on
for i mean it may be the rest of my life
and it may get worse
maybe every day i'll be done at two
o'clock rather than
being able to work till 10 o'clock you
know
um
maybe the mornings will get lost i i
gotta be kind of kind of prudent with
this
then again it could go away tomorrow um
you know maybe it'll get better so that
it only happens at night doesn't happen
in the afternoon
um i gotta start prioritizing a bit more
each day like you know looking at the
things that i'm scheduled to do and
saying
yeah okay this is more important i need
to focus on this in the morning while
i've got the energy or the early
afternoon
this is the optional stuff that i'll put
off towards evening and if it happens it
happens if it doesn't it doesn't
and i i've got and this is a very big
big challenge not just for me but for so
many people including many of my clients
as well
um so you know
i'm not resourceless when it comes to
this but i got to learn how to be
okay
really okay
with
getting less done
getting less accomplished being able to
to do
less in part because um
you know as i get older that's probably
where things go anyway
and in part because i don't need to do
so much you know i already do a hell of
a lot anyway
so
you know maybe
doing half of what i do would be be okay
i don't know
um and so you know here's i don't have
this fully worked out but here's where i
am now and and if this is useful for any
of you that's cool if it's just you take
an interest and you watch this long
that's cool too thanks for doing that so
you know accepting the situation without
lapsing into despair
or pessimism i've been pretty good about
doing that so far but that's kind of a
talent i've built up
anyway over over these years and i'll
tell you studying philosophy
particularly practical philosophy
particularly
you know stoicism
aristotelianism
uh platonism existentialism very helpful
with all of that i've found you know
so there's some fruits there um valuing
what i've
actually got accomplished or produced or
offered to
people or where it was able to
give or provide rather than looking at
what i didn't get done that's that's
really important as well
um
self-care is is uh
important there's a tendency for a lot
of us workaholics to skimp on that
um or duty-driven people right and
self-care doesn't just include like as
i've been doing you know reading in a
nice hot bubble bath which is one of my
my favorite things to do at night or um
you know eating good food or things like
that
it also includes um you know connecting
and maintaining relationships
um with friends and family and
colleagues
it also includes uh the house you know
um tidying up these these uh
always messed up bookshelves can be part
of self-care you know because i have to
look at this stuff right uh so it's nice
to have a good environment
exercise can be part of self-care as
well you know so long as you're doing it
in a reasonable way i'm still
pretty much a diy do-it-yourself kind of
person when it comes to a lot of the
things that i do but
it might be time in my life to start
thinking about finding a
virtual personal assistant or something
like that to do some of the stuff that
i'm not that keen on doing you know like
i don't like scheduling you know um
or you know tracking down
various leads and doing the gatekeeping
that that you know separates out the
people who are going to be good clients
from those who
are are not going to be or stuff like
that
and i think i i need to have less
engagement with um
the typical
unhelpful negative people
you know the the what about people the
trolls the
gotcha guys the
uh i'm gonna write a you know long
screed that i want you to somehow
respond to
um you know the complainers and people
like that i mean i do a good job of
filtering out a lot of those people and
blocking them if they're really a pain
in social media or youtube or stuff like
that
but you know maybe i don't even give
them any engagement whatsoever
because you know my time is limited my
energy is limited why shouldn't i spend
it on people who
really are interested in ideas you know
and are not going to be
uh jerks about it or you know um
obnoxious
about it
um
you know and and to bring this to a
close
bigger picture stuff you know like i
mentioned i'm 51 years old
i'm probably never going to retire
because i love the sort of things that i
do you know but i do definitely have to
think about how i'm going to
find a way of of doing these things
that's ultimately much more sustainable
you know
that can accommodate perhaps having
long-term fatigue
uh unpredictably hitting me at various
points in the day due to covet or you
know whatever else is going to come
along i i have no idea what the future
holds
so i need to think about you know
bigger picture stuff like
where's my next chapters
you know what what do i really want to
be doing
um and rest assured those of you who at
hearing that are like oh i hope he
doesn't stop doing youtube videos i'm
going to be on youtube i'll stay on
youtube basically until the medium turns
into something unrecognizable
i'm going to keep doing that but you
know i want to get more writing done i i
think i want to do more public speaking
but you know certain kinds not not just
pick anything whatsoever and i want to
think about what would be sustainable
for me i think this is a good goal what
would be sustainable for me
into my 70s i don't need to think about
what i'm going to do in my 80s or 90s if
i live that long
it's enough if i can figure out how i'm
going to get from 51
to 70 and and be well set up for that
and so you know this has been uh
kind of a good wake-up call for me
it's not pleasant to have kovid
and it's not
it's not good to have the fatigue
but it has been good in that respect
provoking some you know thinking things
out on my part that
really needed to be done
and so that's it that i don't have
anything more i don't have the whole
thing figured out but hopefully this has
been
interesting and perhaps useful for you
if you've if you're suffering from
uh
you know
covid
long-term effects you got my sympathy
and uh it's
this is part of uh
dealing with the the problems of life
you know you look at ancient philosophy
illnesses are one of the things that
practical philosophy helps us
figure out how to deal with so that's it
for
what are we going to call this the covid
talk or the covid report and i hope that
all of you stay
you know safe and healthy and uh move
your way towards you know a good life
and towards happiness
you